Another issue we come across when
we're working with data is finding
extra characters in fields.
This could be anything,
like currency symbols or number signs.
We'd need to remove these before
changing between field types.
For example, we might need to
change strings to number types so
we can do arithmetic.
We may be working with fields with
strange symbols in them because they
come from some system that automatically
embeds these symbols in the field.
The easiest way to fix
up these types of errors
is to simply get rid of the characters.
In this session, we're going to look at
three different problems where we find
extra characters in fields.
In the first situation,
we've got quotation marks around names,
which we need to remove.
The second field has
a letter after the zip code.
And then third,
a currency symbol at the beginning
of the number in the amount field.
[BLANK_AUDIO]